the u.s has ordered millions i believe
it's 13 million monkey pox vaccines
from a nordic country a company and i
believe they're also basically smallpox
vaccines which i thought was kind of
weird because we eradicated smallpox but
they decided to order all these vaccines
and i thought it was weird that the bulk
of the order has already been
manufactured so for some reason
something happened where
this uh this company i believe it's
danish company decided that it would be
profitable to start mass producing
millions of doses of a monkey pox and
smallpox vaccine well we are in luck
because now we have what is being called
a global outbreak now it's a little
preliminary there are i think nine
countries
one of which there is a suspected case
but in eight there are confirmed cases
of monkey pox
the media is hyping it up a little bit
we've got to break down what it really
means but
as much as this may just be shock and
fear
you've got election year coming up
yeah it may just be shock and fear this
may be just an attempt to rile people up
invoke fear of the coveted lockdown and
then maybe use that fear to try and help
or i should say exploit that fear to win
an election so you got to be careful
about what the media is saying about
this so we're going to break down what's
going on and what people are saying
about the monkey pox outbreak it's
already got its wikipedia entry i
believe there's 34 confirmed cases we
have a potential case in manhattan we
have a confirmed case in massachusetts
17 potential cases in montreal
23 potential cases in spain and uh it's
actually scary because
if this is the bad monkey box the
mortality rate is ten percent if it's
like the not that bad monkey pox its
mortality rate is ju is less than one
percent so we'll see we'll talk about
that and then we'll talk about all the
other controversies we got gas prices
expected to hit six dollars in average
per uh i'm sorry six dollars per gallon
average by august
twitter has announced new censorship
policies
and uh the smear pieces on elon musk
have dropped they're accusing him of
sexual impropriety we'll call it that
and then we've got some other funny
stories uh the woman from the cover of
that sports illustrated the the chunky
woman chunky queen she snapped back at
jordan peterson so maybe we'll talk
about that again i also tweeted
something about fat acceptance and of
course all the uh all these i guess fat
people are mad at me i don't know it's
not a political thing so i'm assuming
people are mad or probably overweight or
something i mean i lost a ton of weight
as of november so you know so traitor
yes absolutely joining us
to have a conversation hang out on this
thursday is lily tang williams
hi team thanks for having me back
absolutely do you want to introduce
yourself yes i'm a lady tom williams
actually in the history of new hampshire
first time
a chinese immigrant is running for
congress in city too
so i welcome people to check me out
lilitangwiliams.com i'm on social media
twitter instagram and youtube that's a
win for diversity i'm sure the democrats
love you
well
dwight are you saying they don't
actually believe in that
how absurd an immigrant
yeah
a a female person of color running i
mean that's that's everything they
should be they should be proud of well
don't write them off yeah i think people
have been very nice to me i do have lots
of
undeclared independence even moderate
democrats i truly believe if they like
me they like my messages they feel
they can trust me and they could vote
for me so you know we have to keep it
positive right yeah well you know what i
hope anyone and everyone who's
considering voting for you does it is
great to have you back i am sheamus of
freedom students we just uploaded a
cartoon today on leftists rediscovering
biology if you guys want to check that
out it's in response to roe v wade i
think you all will enjoy that's over at
freedom tunes also we're going to be
launching the freedom tunes website on
may 30th go over there uh it's still
under construction but you'll be able to
put your email address in to get
notified when we launch
what's up everybody i am a lot i do a
lot of on the ground reporting for tim
cast excited to talk to lily about her
candidacy and a lot of other news that
we got coming up
i'm very excited for tonight we love
lilly over here i think this is her
third time here three times a term she's
a lovely lady and let's get into it
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member and help
support our work as a member you'll get
access access to exclusive segments of
the tim cast irl podcast at 11 pm monday
through thursday we'll have another one
of those up tonight and you will also be
supporting our journalists and our
infrastructure because we work with
rumble for all of our infrastructure
needs on the website that means as a
member you are supporting the
alternative technology infrastructure
and ecosystem
and we are competing with bit with
silicon valley big tech and we are
resistant to censorship so that's
another reason to to get behind the work
we do as well as rumble and everyone
else in in the space
we have uh more uh updates coming on the
uh coming up in regards to the
infrastructure that we're working on so
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and let's jump into
that first story from the new york post
the u.s buys millions of monkey pox
vaccines after massachusetts confirms
case the u.s has ordered 13 million
additional doses of the monkey pox
vaccine after a massachusetts man
contracted the rare but potentially
severe virus
the massive 119 million dollar order of
the genios jabs which can be used to
treat both the monkeypox virus and
smallpox
was created by the biotechnology company
bavarian nordic according newsweek in
2015 the cdc
uh uh center for news control approved
the use of the genios as a vaccine for
the rare virus monkey boxes versus
covered in 58 blah blah blah symptoms
include fever headache body aches
swollen lymph nodes chills exhaustion in
some cases rashes within recent years
there have been several flare-ups of the
disease several of them in the uk two
cases were imported in the u.s in 2021
however if you head over to the
wikipedia entry for the 2022 monkey pox
outbreak i think perhaps
we could um
ask some questions about why it already
has a wikipedia entry and what's
happening this year where uh this kind
of story could greatly benefit someone
and well it's politics now before we get
into all that they're saying the virus
strain is the west african clade of the
monkey pox virus which has a mortality
rate my understanding is less than one
percent
they say but however they do say
uh although usually uh
monkey pox generally presents with
similar symptoms to smallpox although
usually milder however the case fatality
rate for monkey pox may still be as high
as high as 10 percent without prompt
treatment
if you go down
we have the uk spain portugal the us
sweden italy belgium canada and france
now in canada and france there are
suspected cases not confirmed cases but
in the seven other countries we have
confirmed cases totaling 34 perhaps
nothing
right perhaps this is just something
happens every year
and maybe the media's latched down to it
because
it'll generate clicks
maybe it can be used to scare people for
an election or
maybe they just purchased 13 million
monkey pox vaccines for a reason
i told luke gurkowski on the show what
was this before january
i thought we'd see a lockdown this year
because of the midterms and the
democrats didn't have anything else he
said no they're gonna they're not gonna
do it they're not gonna do it they can't
tonight and then after a few months said
you know what i think luke's right
they're pulling the lockdowns back
i still think it would be a stretch that
they would lock down over this but when
you've got a virus and they're going
around saying a 10 mortality rate
i wonder
if they'll actually try and pull off
another lockdown
i think we need to take all potential
pandemics very seriously but um the
issue here right now is that the trust
in the cdc is at an all-time low so i
think information surrounding this virus
is going to be very untrusted and maybe
rightfully so again we already have like
a wikipedia page about this um i think
at one point it said it's endemic in
nigeria
well some people from nigeria have
gotten it but the west african clade of
the monkey pox virus is uh what they're
saying now yeah so i remember thinking
originally when they had like the 14
days to stop the spread that we wouldn't
be able to sustain that in our public
wouldn't be able to you know wouldn't
put up with that and i was so off base
with what that was so i i don't know
what's going on with this what do you
guys think
well i think uh people should learn
enough from past two years
what is our trust level today
on the
media or our government agencies
right
there's it's very low
and i still have lots of questions never
got answered
and we're still waiting for more and
more evidence more truth to come out
and
this this kind of stuff you know like we
we have
always always left you know with lots of
stuff in the past and i think people are
ready to move on have no more life back
there's still lots of mental health
issues our children our people have not
even got resolved yet i have a friend
who's got lung covey she cannot have
solutions she's still coughing
so i i'm just not really ready for this
you know i hope people will have more
questions instead of jumping into what
the media is saying
yeah i would agree and i think a lot of
people aren't going to jump to what the
media is saying even if this does turn
out to be something substantial and it
really is a risk people aren't going to
be willing to trust the media in the cdc
and for good reason because they spent
the last two years completely
undermining any credibility they may
have had with the american people
i'm just i'm just imagining fauci you
know when the news broke you was like
thank you
and he's like he's he opens his closet
and there's a whole bunch of different
masks puts his top head on in his cane
he starts singing but he's like he picks
out his tie and then he also pulls out
he's got all the masks lined up and
there's like different pens
and i'll take this one then he puts it
on and he gets ready
and how many people will still call him
now king fauci i don't know well he did
say he would resign if donald trump got
elected really yeah so everybody was
like okay hey vote for him so we'll vote
for donald trump donald trump
is a vote against fouchy and joe biden
why would he campaign for trump like
that
i'm kind of questioning who this could
potentially help politically this
becoming a big story in the news and the
only people i could write like initially
think that this could help is the people
who effed up big time during the covet
pandemic
and you know with with certain lockdowns
who does this help you know we kind of
memory hold you know the origin of covet
and holding people responsible for covid
who may have let it out or you know
helped exacerbate the issue around the
planet so this could potentially help
them i also know it's it's called monkey
pox so maybe this is just like an
anti-monkey lobbyist group because i
know with you know the china virus we
were concerned about hate crimes because
of that and now why are they calling
this monkey pox a little bit insensitive
because it was first isolated monkeys oh
that makes too much sense so i pulled up
red well i was told corona was first
isolated in a bat that's right so right
so when i pulled up reddit you take a
look at the comments someone comments on
why he says i don't understand why so
many comments are being removed and the
response is all i know is covet 19
started just like this news of
infections all over europe then to the
u.s but it's contained and then all of a
sudden bam lock down i expect anything
to happen nowadays
and then uh someone said well we have
two years of contact tracing so we
should be able to easily find that
exposure oh yeah right also wait i just
want to make a point i was making a joke
earlier but i actually still want to
correct this i said isolating a bat it
was never isolated in a bat they just
said it came from a bat when they were
talking about in new york city they just
changed the covet alert to high and
people are already prepared to start
masking again so if this spreads even a
little bit some places in the country
are willing to lock down over relatively
small things again and
are happy too
and china one quarter of population
under kobe lockdown for omaqua
you know it's like what talk about
something else is coming you're talking
about 18 trinity dollars economy in
china one quarter of them are under
lockdown and we're going to sue
food shortages supply issues and people
have no access to medicine medical care
and they're committed suicide and we
don't see the lots of report on that and
condemn this kind of human
treatment of of their citizens and now
we're talking about this is like it's
insane world you know we talked about
the uh the rat hope experiment before
so this was where the guy puts the rat
in the cylinder full of water
the rat can't get out and then within 15
minutes it just gives up and then sinks
to the bottom and dies
but then he puts another rat in
after right right when it's about to
give up and it starts sinking he pulls
it out dries it off lets it rest picks
it up puts it back in this time the rats
would swim for an average of 60 hours
because they thought there was hope that
if they just waited somebody would pull
them out
and i'm feeling like this is what we're
bumping into after coven you know we get
two years of this insanity everybody's
about to lose their mind and then also
everything goes back to normal now you
get monkey pox and what's to say i'm not
saying it will happen if they lock down
people are going to be like i can handle
i can handle the lockdown we know if we
just wait long enough eventually we'll
get through this and then this time
it'll be five years
five years of weird lockdown people
starving locked in their homes doors
welded shut like what's going on in
china right now
i know it's like a two years ago right
wuhan lockdown like 13 million people
now shanghai is 25 million and the whole
country 45 cities you're talking about
370 million people under lockdown and
they censor all the information like how
many people are dying of lack of food
medical care and access to medicine and
how many people committed suicide there
are lots of videos on weight change as
soon as i get to it
say no it's gone this violates our
regulation it sounds like there's some
notice i would get from facebook you
know and it just it's so sad for me to
say because i have lots of friends in
shanghai i went to college there i
worked there for seven years total time
in shanghai
and
imagine those people who support
economic reform have a good life and
retire now and they have money and they
cannot buy food and i have one friend
even commented i i get it now why
americans hold on to their guns
even chinese get it now it's like
because they got locked down by the
wires
electrical wires on their steps to go
out so they cannot get out you can get
some fresh air and totally rely on
government delivery food who gets
priorities if you have 25 million people
of course people who are high up with
connections
it's madness and the farmers see their
vegetable dying of getting rotten
because there's a total breakdown
between the food supply and to the end
user customers
so
roads are blocked you have to have mass
massive testing
so people cannot get to the food and the
people have power guess what they do
they hold food or they sell for very
high prices
and those people who were white clothes
you see all those terrible videos guess
what their new names it's a white guard
instead of raid guards under mouse china
white guards yes and they're total nuts
very suckish one girl was raped by
leaving along and the white guard coming
and not just raped her but also killed
her mom and said please help my daughter
is dead
and it's like it's so heartbroken you
know that's why i'm running i i don't
want this ever come to america
i think new hampshire is relatively safe
but it's mostly because of people like
you in the free state project because
new hampshire is moving fur like closer
and closer to freedom further and
further away from the establishment the
authoritarianism
but i would not be surprised if we got
locked onto this and it and it's early
it's early this could be a blip and then
within a week there's no story it's gone
and it was like false alarm everybody i
just kind of feel like when i saw that
they already made a wikipedia entry for
it i'm like somebody with time and
energy
decided to make an entry for an outbreak
when we're at 34 cases is that really a
global outbreak is that i guess so i
guess so so uh i'm just i just wonder
well the plan is a lot bigger than just
oh recently you show up in wikipedia
think about the former kgb guy urine
what he said 40 years ago he died you
know and he said
the communists will infiltrate into
america
and they're going to take two
generations to bring down united states
america
why two generations he said well you got
to have four steps number one step is
demoralize a society then destabilize it
then you go through crisis and crisis
situations then you're trying to
normalize it but when they're trying to
normalize it
you rights and freedom all gone it's
their normalization i'm terrified to say
there's this craziness going on in the
world i know new hampshire is great
that's why i moved there but i'm worried
about the whole country because i have
three children who are born in this
country they're living in other states
right now yeah
i'm not i'm not sure we can we can pull
back i think maybe we've gone off the
edge of the cliff a long time ago and
now it's a free fall
right with just uh we've been
demoralized now we're destabilized and i
don't think there is a coming back
because
there's just too many people in this
country that don't care to know
but want power
and when you take ignorant people
lazy ignorant people who desire power
because they think they're smarter than
you they destroy things
these are the kind of people that you
know we're in a car and we're driving
straight towards the edge about to go
off the cliff and you got the person in
the right side the person on the left
side
the person in the right keeps saying
stop
turn turn turn the person on the left is
like no i'm right i know what i'm doing
and then straight off the edge of the
cliff but their part of the plan is
called
indoctrination of the youth take away
parental rights kids belong to this
state and believe in marxism and
socialism and free stuff and guess who
are they today
social justice lawyers work activists or
whatever you call them
i don't know it's it's really we have to
blame
ourselves our educational system really
when you think about it hong kong people
young people go out to risk their life
to protest want to democracy they want
freedom and and and even one the second
moment our young people here
please
have more gun control take my guns away
i agree and sadly it's not just the
young people it's the older people who
don't really care about the young and
aren't really interested in protecting
the youth so for example we have a cdc
report which said youth suicide attempts
soared uh during the pandemics i mean
you lock kids in their homes you take
away normal social settings and
situations they're going to be more
likely to get depressed we also know
that they had mask mandates for children
in new york children were the last
people who were still required to wear
masks they're still required to wear
them now right now exactly and so
adults aren't doing their responsibility
in protecting children from this kind of
stuff and you would think those are the
most vulnerable
of our society little young kids who
don't know what's going on lose valuable
time of learning years i heard the p
like kids who under four they lost two
years to speak properly because
everybody's wear a mask and you know
hide their faces cannot develop their
social skills and they're going through
speech therapy right now it's like even
article published by the atlantic it's
like my case needs speech therapy
exactly and so i think we've seen this
one of the the strategies of the
communist movement is to try to break
down the family and so it's going in
both directions firstly you see it is
very much the case that children don't
respect their parents anymore and they
look to the states to find solutions
they look to the state to find solutions
to problems rather than to the family
structure and also of course as i just
mentioned parents are not really
interested in protecting their children
either this really goes in both
directions the family has very much been
chipped away at from every angle i want
to make a point on that but i do want to
make a point on the speech thing real
quick
you ever watch a tv show and the volume
is just a little too low
but you can tell what they're saying by
how their mouth is
yeah and then you like look down at your
phone and now all of a sudden the clear
words become well round
seeing the mouth movements
really does
we are we are verbal and visual
communicators vocal and visual and all
these kids now these little kids all
they saw was masks
so their their their brain was like not
getting the full communications
experience now these kids like you
mentioned they're in therapy or they're
going to grow up and they're going to be
stunted yes so going back to what you
were saying about the family i mean uh
absolutely and i agree that a lot of
parents
um well i'll say it myself i don't think
a lot of parents care about their kids
no i think they uh care about them in a
superficial way
but i'm surprised to hear these stories
every day where it's like
look we had this video from libs of tick
tock where a mother says my 15 year old
daughter was given pornographic material
to do an assignment on and she was
mortified and when she tried reading the
assignment they told her to stop talking
because it was too vulgar for the
meeting and this is like the fifth story
we've seen about this and she was like
my daughter was given this
where were the other parents huh why was
just this one mother speaking about this
where were how many parents how many
kids are in a school right you've got
you've got what a thousand maybe or more
shouldn't there be hundreds of parents
showing up being like why were my
children given this no they're not
they're not showing up they have no idea
it's it's insane to me just look i i get
it i don't have kids but my when i grew
up my parents asked me about school all
the time how was school what did you
learn and they would ask me questions
and they would give me answers to just
the idea that you'd come home and they'd
be like meh and have no idea what the
teachers were that were grooming you for
i know it's sad that when we raised our
three children you know we they went to
public school and in douglas county
colorado we know that we have to have
family dinner together every night and
then we talk to them about school and
then we ask them actually tough
questions so they have to tell us what's
going on what the teacher you know
taught them so we have to basically
program them you have to do this as
families you know if you cannot afford
private school you cannot afford to come
school you gotta have a conversation
with your kids you know i you cannot
just treat squeeze babysitters go to
school hours hours long then we do our
business we do our work and the kids
come home there's a very funny meme like
some kids go to college at the age of 18
and come back look like total car marks
here goes you still don't know money you
pay for it
i
i just i i wonder if it's it's a
communist plot or if it's just
domino's falling over yeah if you look
at uh the 70s with women's liberation
right a lot of people don't understand i
think it was 1974. pre-1974 women
couldn't get credit cards without their
husband's signature so it's like you're
not married too bad something like that
fact should be on that one yeah but i've
heard a lot of those stories but we do
know that in the late 70s more and more
women started enter the workplace all of
a sudden the workforce doubles
well if the supply of workers doubles
but the demand stays the same workers
are going to be losing out because they
have no negotiating power all of a
sudden now
women who could work
didn't have to
now have to because wages are stagnant
and now you need two incomes to support
your family now without anyone to take
care of the family you need somewhere to
put your kids but you can't afford
daycare so public schools come around
now your kids are handed off to the
state the next step is these kids are
raised by
the state
employees like literal agents of the
state and they grow up
now you've got the millennial generation
which is split between many
i don't know average people and then a
whole bunch of pro-government socialist
kids
uh i'm not gonna call them adults
they're they're still they're they're
old children we'll call it that
and now they're advocating for an
expansion upon
the government controlling more and more
lives but why they were raised by the
government they weren't raised by their
parents they were raised in government
institutions
that's freaky to me
and their teachers are trained by
marxist professors in teachers colleges
you know how many teachers college in
the country those teachers can become
our kids teachers
and when i when i go to school talk
about cultural revolution how many
people died under mouse communism and
all the details horrors some teachers
our democrats said oh lily we we never
knew that
so if they don't know how do they teach
our kids real history
or is that there like a
left side of story of history 100
million people died under 100 years of
communism
and and some people were saying they did
not do that right they did not do the
socialism companies like how many people
are you gonna experiment with this
ideology i wonder if you got bill gates
in private you know and he knew that he
was safe what he would say about the
communist dictatorships
he's a guy who's given talks saying we
need to reduce population growth and and
i wonder because certainly the
communists
effectively reduced population growth
you know by exterminating hundreds 100
million people which is
horrifying and the other one child
policy as well right right right and
starving to this
i'm not i'm not accusing bill gates of
anything i'm i'm genuinely curious what
he might think of that because if he's a
utilitarian and he seems to be and
imagine he'd be like well you know
positive outcome i guess
by the way i just want to mention so i
did just a little bit of googling here
since you mentioned the thing about
women not being able to get credit cards
what i'm reading is that it was the case
that before there was an
anti-discrimination law a bank could
deny them a credit card i'm not sure how
often it happens one website is saying
that they could face a barrage of
questions when trying to get a credit
card that men wouldn't face but i'm not
like seeing any numbers on how common
but also people need to understand this
because i see feminists say all the time
they're like did you know that women
could get credit cards unless their
husband signed off on it it's like did
you know that women mostly weren't
working so the bank would be like how do
you intend to pay for this and they'd be
like my husband has a job and they'd be
like okay well then your husband needs
to certify this
that doesn't sound as nefarious now does
it yeah to follow up on those millennial
parents um i think i feel like there's a
few things at play here first of all
there's more single parents than ever
before and i feel like millennials have
become more willing to embrace that and
another video that i saw from libs from
tiktok who's doing an extraordinary job
and probably one of the most influential
people in our parts of of the political
space but it was this one mother in a
dressing room with her child
do you guys know what i'm talking about
with this dress and at the end of every
sentence she would say she would just be
like right you love this dress right
like you picked out this dress right
like you feel good you want to buy this
dress they make fun of you at school you
know they make fun of me too and then it
like pans to herself and it's her
smirking so it's like a lot of these
sing i don't know if she's a single
parent but it's a lot of these single
parents these millennial people
projecting their beliefs onto their
children and it was a non-binary looking
type millennial mother and they're just
so willing to experiment and also like
this idea that wearing dresses makes you
a girl
and like a child would understand that
as a concept that wearing a dress makes
you think you somehow want to transition
to a girl so crazy and unfathomable
unless you project so much of your
gender ideology onto this childhood but
crazy also i mean if she's not a single
parent that father should be
unbelievably ashamed i mean functionally
she is i just i just want to say
um
i feel
i feel bad for people who didn't have
two parents i i mean that genuinely i
know i know people who were in single
family homes and i'm just like
the people that i knew who grew up with
just their dad are just their mom and
their parents are good people trying
really really hard they they did not
have that uh two parent privilege we'll
call it it's twice as much time twice
the income
it's it's uh learning how to bake
cookies with your mom it's playing ball
with your dad or playing ball with your
mom and making cookies with your dad
maybe your dad's a famous chef or baker
maybe your mom's a sports manager or you
know in the in business or she's a
stay-at-home mom who's giving you
individualized attention and caring for
you i remember you know just the the
it's i could not imagine not having a
mom and a dad you know how high is a
talk about black americans
and their family destructions and caused
their kids no role models and home no
debts live on welfare you know the i
heard it's like 70 percent of
you know black family household are lit
just by single mothers where are their
fathers
and there were those role models for
their children their their their their
those young boys they they
they're stuck in in their
and they have no way to get quality
education because democrats control the
school district do not allow school
choice and then they get a board and
they have no interest school they become
against and they get arrested and thrown
into jail for years and years it's
horrible but they don't talk about this
when they talk about black lives matter
let's talk about the cause of their
poverty and their high crime rate the
the opposition to school choice is is
one of the most shocking things to me
because
i'm confused
you've got a low-income neighborhood of
any race
and the parents are like we have no
choice but to send our kids to a
low-income school with low-income
teachers with no resources with school
choice they could literally just go to
the next town over which may be
wealthier and be like we choose this
school
and then that money goes to the school
the school gets bigger and the good
schools then grow and can bring in the
lower income kids into the better
schools
why do they why do they oppose that well
because lots of teachers unions opposed
to it so when people say oh you know and
we we really very concerned for the
people of color well in democrat control
city states they
are in the pockets of teachers unions
and who donate lots of money for their
elections right and the teachers union
you see how they behave during the kobe
they want to use the school reopening as
a negotiation
and condition to say you okay they're
not gonna come back to school until we
get what we want in los angeles it's all
marx's agenda exactly
horrible i mean it's such an incredibly
powerful union because they can
literally keep your children hostage
they say well we're not going to be
giving them an education unless you meet
our demands and it's really unfortunate
because i you know i am not against
collective bargaining i think unions can
be great the teachers unions are not if
they are the perfect example of how it
can absolutely become the case that a
union just ends up being an organization
which protects the weaker workers from
the better workers who would outperform
them and receive more promotions and so
when you see them opposing school choice
my thought is these teachers are
constantly complaining about lower wages
well wouldn't it be the case that if we
had school choice
and educational institutions had to
compete for students they would also
have to compete for good teachers so
that they can ensure a decent
educational quality and get kids to go
there so if you are a good teacher
school choice isn't a threat because
good schools will want you and you'll
have more options as well outside of the
public school system give you example
d.c teachers union shut down a very
popular charter school in d.c
because all the black families and
children they're waiting long lines to
get into this charter school
but they shut that down do they really
care about people of color like they
claim and they're trying to teach
critical race theory into all 14 000
school districts say that you're
oppressed if you're people of color but
do you really care about people of color
to strive to get out of poverty except
sitting there being pressed and say well
victims if you really care about them
then you got to lift them up by having
educational choice for parents for kids
i feel very strongly about it it's my
top three issues defend the parental
rights and parental choice otherwise you
know those kids are stuck in the inner
poor performing schools and no
competition and you can throw all the
money you want to from taxpayers added
and they do not improve in terms of
testing schools you know testing scores
and quality education at the same time
they're taught oh equity equity so
government gave me some how do they take
a personal responsibility to become like
entrepreneurs become good in math and
ratings and science and they're
competing with other country kids for
lots of good jobs right now but instead
they're focused on you know crap they're
teaching school yeah moreover the way
that they're saying that they're helping
these students are actually hurting it's
coming at the cost of other students so
a lot of ways that they're saying
they're helping black and brown people
in these communities is by getting rid
of the upper class classes the honor
classes because they say that it
racially divides children because more
and white asians tend to be in the
honors classes and therefore if we see
any you know not a direct reflection of
population in class sizes and how it's
distributed it's automatically racist so
what do they say they just get rid of
the honors classes and then they say
they're helping everybody but really it
just comes at the cost of our our best
students that's why china like asian
americans families are geared moving
into more and more voting for
republicans because they value education
they value their kids and quality of
their education now they say all this
stuff oh my case the ap class is
cancelled and also 18 children when
they're trying to apply for harvard yale
they get discriminated because there's a
quotas
they're too excellent you cannot go if
we you know you have to wait at the
bottom of the line once the quarters is
gone and the doj dropped the lawsuit
against yale when when the aging parents
are sued yale to say your discriminatory
girls are against our kids based on skin
color because they're aging but instead
look at the individual meritocracy which
this country is supposed to be and the
left word say oh your agents are too
rich oh it's for the class economical
class it's a classical marxist series
it's oh we have highest income in the
country than white so now in washington
state if you're 18 children you're
supposed to go to the white group
because you
you make too much money
yeah absolutely i think part of this is
a symptom of how completely economically
illiterate the left is so it seems to me
as if they more or less see the economy
as something which serves us by giving
people busy work
to keep them focused on other things all
day they don't actually understand how
supply chains work that's part of why
they they had no apprehensions about
shutting the entire economy down they
don't understand where goods and
services really come from and the fact
that the work people do in our economy
is important and so they will look at
any particular field and they'll say we
need to make sure that this is equitable
we need to make sure that we see a
perfect demographic breakdown of the
population here otherwise it's unfair
instead of going oh well given that the
purpose of an economy is to deliver
goods and services these people are in
this field because they found their way
there because they're best at doing it
and maybe it is better for us to have
people who are good at jobs do them
instead of shoehorning people into
positions or out of them based on their
ethnic identity and one more thing i
want to mention is the left has
constantly claimed that they are the
party and ideology of education and
higher learning firstly they have flat
out lied about that for years they've
claimed that uh we're constantly
slashing funding for education it's
literally not true federal spending per
pupil has increased every single year
since 1970 test scores have not
increased and by the way that's an
increase in funding adjusted for
inflation as well and so
with all this extra money we've been
spending on education at the federal
level what are they doing like you said
cutting gifted classes giving fewer
children opportunities to excel
it's sickening it's interesting because
we keep hearing about this potential
asian backlash against the democratic
party but i don't know if it's ever come
to fruition because these cases against
like yell and harvard have been going on
it for i feel like almost a decade now
we're also seeing hate crimes towards
asians in a lot of different communities
that we're waiting to see this backlash
from also on the education front but i
i don't know
what percentage of the united states is
asian i think it's relatively small but
in certain areas they have
i think they're um gathered around the
coasts mostly so in specific areas they
might have outsized influence as i
understand in new york city and
chinatown asians are the chinese
specifically are some of the least
politically involved um and they refuse
they don't refuse to vote but they just
don't and it's interesting because
there's a lot of reasons for that the
system that they came from in china
obviously they didn't have the
opportunity to vote in the past also
there's this language barrier that
exists still in a lot of these chinese
immigrant communities so there's a lot
of seven percent seven percent seven
percent
new hampshire is uh asian americans is
three percent but it is the second
largest minority group
so i think i'm not sure that the
democrats are worried about seven
percent when we when they were talking
about uh bill maher was talking about
student debt forgiveness bill maher said
13
of americans have student debt not a
large group
and he's outright saying like why why
would we be focused on this 13 well
asians are seven i certainly think the
democrats don't care
i've mentioned this on the show many
times when i was younger i was told
never to check asian off on any form and
ask my from ask for my race because i
was told you will be discriminated
against
based on the assumptions they make about
asians so you're better off just putting
you know white down or something but
they use us when they want to advance
their agenda called stop aging hate
right you know why the races white
supremacists are taking agents according
to dog data 2018 most crimes happened
against the agents you know what they
are people of color
yeah i think asians are also scared to
talk about this one rep his name is john
liu
in lower manhattan i've spoken to him
about this and what did he say when he
was trying to address these hate crimes
he was telling me about like education
classes i also think there's an issue
here with influential asian people in
the culture in media unwilling to call
out this crime specifically because
they're scared to get labeled because
they're scared to get labeled racist and
um yeah it's it's a sad fact to reality
well it's uh it's very sad for me i have
been telling people
i see similarities between mouse
cultural revolution and with what's
going on in today's america and in
instead we use a you know classes here
just use racist it's everything's about
race everything's about your skin color
instead of your diversity of ideas and
thoughts personality and skills and
knowledge right i will i love diversity
like you use it you know we're all part
of diversity but they only talk about
diversity of the skin color which is
which is wrong and also well not only
that they only talk about diversity of
skin color when they consider it to be
uh advantageous to them or diversity of
ethnicity when it's advantageous to them
we were just mentioning the fact that
they want fewer asian students in
universities and you mentioned the asian
hate that there's hate crimes against
asians well this is just the inevitable
byproduct of critical theory as applied
to race when you spend decades telling
the black community
that the white community is only
successful only doing well because they
have stolen something from you that
instills in the psyche of the general
public that if any group of people is
outperforming another group of people it
is because they have victimized that
group so the inevitable conclusion from
that kind of logic is that asian people
have cheated in some way so the
expectation is that we would see more
crimes against them
it's an insane ideology based on greed
and envy and it is to blame for these
hate crimes there's no question about it
you know what's really funny
that there are stereotypes and tropes
about asian parents
you watch any comedy show and the asian
parent is demanding of their of their
kid to get better grades you know a
futurama uh i had the joke i think it's
the trauma are you a doctor yet or was
that uh what was it it was a different
show anyway the the point is might have
been futurama it might have been future
oh yeah if you don't get a straight a
you better explain to your parents why
you did not get straight in i don't know
my kids would come blame about me
there's there's what they call positive
discrimination stereotype against asians
that the asian parent is a strict
academic and then all of a sudden
they're like how come asians make more
money we should we should uh imagine
this
your parents are strict and tell you to
work hard study hard and get to the best
school so the school says make it harder
so what what's what's the outcome then
the parents would be like it doesn't
matter if you work hard because the
school's not gonna let you in anyway
and then once the scores start dropping
they'll be like ah okay now we can let
them back in because they're not doing
as well
it's insane they're saying is though and
and traditionally culturalize that the
aging parents always value education
because that's the only way they can get
out of poverty look at the chinese
people who come from china like me who
started with nothing and because of the
education the skills the degree we got
we get good jobs we start on business we
work their butt off and to achieve
american dream we're not rich we have no
connection in this country we have no
social status we have no inheritance
money in this country it is a hard work
ethics make us successful
and you i have seen parents from china
running restaurant look how hard work
that is seven days a week no vacations
they send their kids fifty thousand
dollars a year to harvard and now
there's like
oh my kids cannot get in no matter how
high their act is and now you take act
might be racist now this is this is a
question i i would love to see it is by
the way we have the trope of we have the
trope of the student going to college
and then coming back with their head
shaved and purple hair what would happen
to a kid who's in an asian family the
asian parents are very strict saying you
better score really high in sats you're
going to go to harvard and then they
score really really well and they're
wearing like a suit a tie and they go
off to the university and then come home
to their asian family
with their head shaved purple hair and
they're wearing like cut off sleeves and
like sweatpants like whatever dad i
don't care anymore call me janet
i want to mention you said something
about the acts there are sats there are
people who consider the sats and acts to
be racially biased so they are
considered racist as well you know i'm
aware of any disparity
that exists
but here's something you might not know
canceling academic
achievement excellence is what mao did
during china's cultural revolution one
guy
after cultural revolution like a school
reopened he was taking a test
and he said i don't care about this i'm
gonna turn in my test blank so he got a
big zero right guess what he's a
glorious they made him a hero
and his name is donkey shannon i
remember that very well so now i'm
saying the same thing happened in this
country
casually individual excellence
in academic in science in art in comedy
issues
can you say why i'm warning people this
is cultural revolution happening in
america yeah scary stuff tim you
mentioned how um a lot of these asian
immigrants uh parents are sending their
kids to college they're coming back
head-to-head i'm not saying they are i'm
saying i wonder what that like it's one
thing if you're a liberal you know
american and your kid comes back and
they're they're doing all these things
and they believe all this weird stuff
and these liberals are going to be like
oh very progressive of you honey but for
like a strict conservative asian parent
for that to happen to their kids they
might be like what i'm not saying this
is the exact same thing but i want to
draw a parallel but the cultural
revolution was actually led by the youth
right in in china's
were all the youth in the schools that
were the leaders of this so that same
parallel that we're seeing in the
universities that happened in china we
are seeing to some degree here as well
because kids are going to college
becoming more indoctrinated coming back
to their home and the parents don't
understand what their kids can but they
don't know the history that's what i'm
saying they even don't know they were
some of them praise it i know people who
think what's happening in china and
what's happened in the past is a good
thing i know people online on twitter i
feel like it's easy to find people
denying that the
tiananmen square massacre even happened
so
we do nursing wow that uh if you were in
this country even deny that it's like we
should shoot them a tank man
so
what's uh we've heard a lot of stories
about
chinese spies coming to the united
states and taking action against chinese
citizens who are not living in the
united states
has this has anything happened to you i
mean you're running for office you're
gaining a lot of influence you believe
in freedom you're speaking out against
the ccp quite a bit
is this something you've noticed well my
last time honestly went to
see my family and friends in china was
2015. i bought air ticket to go back
2019 but by then i was already big on
social media and going to schools
educated people about horrors of
communism and somehow they found my
english page and they started to come to
my social media threatened me and said
you better not ever come back to china
so 2019 i wasn't running for anything i
was just educator inspirational speaker
so i i i told my husband
he said you better not go back by
yourself because i have to work and
we're getting ready to move to new
hampshire if you disappear the nature in
it don't look don't let you come back
what i'm gonna do
so i wasn't i wasn't anybody so i was
just like small cabbage you know you
know not famous and i said okay i'll
cancel my trip so and now i'm running as
a republican kennedy and still be
consistent speak out against ccp
when i was giving speech in utah near
salt lake city
one chinese man showed up in his 30s
and paid 75 dollars tape my whole talk
then tell people at the table
you all been brainwashed by her
our leaders in china are not elected
they are like our fathers so so that
people people told me later lately did
he come to say hi i said no i never met
him i don't know who he is and i tell my
chinese friends
of course his spy don't put your
location on social media so they can
show up and troll you and the worst
comes they can attack you so now i said
okay like i i didn't tell people i'm
coming here today tonight until
afterwards you know it's uh
well i feel like i have friends worried
about my safety and they say don't run
for congress do something else i say
well if i want to make message to be
heard by people in this country and the
free world even people who are voice
inside the china i'm the best person to
tell the truth and speak truth to the
power just keep that in mind they've
been targeting me and trying to
discredit my campaign and call me a
china spy
and so i was telling teams like just
believe me me i will never disappear
okay and i will never kill myself i
don't have any mental health issues can
we also get your reaction to the church
shooting that happened in california
from this apparently guy who i'm reading
from the taipei times right now that
says the suspect was tied to a
pro-chinese
group and there was this heroic
taiwanese man he was this doctor who
rushed the shooter um this has gotten a
lot less coverage than other mass
shootings that have occurred so could
you say chinese against chinese right
taiwanese taiwanese yeah no but they
speak mandarin asians aren't a monolith
yeah right right they don't report it
what happens is that i'm saying that
they have infiltrated into this country
since the confucius institute started
like 18 years ago the last one just
closed on campus of
university of new hampshire like the end
of last year
and they were allowed infiltrated in our
schools and colleges to induct with our
children make china look glorious and
also the chinese newspapers can
distribute to our congress people in the
capital here a lot long ago called the
people's daily they paid money to put
that newspaper insert into our newspaper
here in the united states give to our
congress people and your talk about
infiltration
i have a chinese human rights activist
he almost got killed in california
recently five chinese spies were
indicted by doj three were arrested and
one of them is american not even chinese
so don't don't assume they're just like
look like me they don't they are
everywhere not a few years ago i read
article there were over 30 000 ccp spies
all shapes and all colors all people and
there is something to say too about the
amount of chinese immigrant students
that come here just for a few years and
end up going back and forth for a bit i
know covet did put a little bit of a
dent in that but this is only the spies
that we know about if we can only
imagine how many of these that we don't
well some of them there are two kinds of
students one come by themselves and
their family money their own money
another kind is send by the government
and together even unpaid by the
government and they have duty to go back
and to bring all their knowledge so
think about all the potential uh
economic expelage working in our
laboratories and steal the secrets from
the high-tech companies and take back to
china and i think uh the national
security people are aware of this but it
is still
mine you know like a confusing to me who
let those people come in here
into our schools into the like harvard
for example took a lot of money also
from china they did not even report to
the department of education you're
supposed to report if you take foreign
money and i think she's daughter
actually went to harvard if i'm not
mistaken
well connected right it's interesting
how she didn't choose to go to any you
know shanghai university she chose
harvard and they even recoup talent just
called a tenant recruiting program in
the world by and she
and they remember our um athletes
competed for china team during winter
olympics right right right yeah and she
might even maybe choose to do
citizenship even though china do not
allow do certain ship well i don't know
if they're going to make exception for
her or not and her mom is from china i
thought didn't she resign like are she
renounced u.s citizenship to compete for
china or something like that yes one
ghoul i think uh yeah she stood up
really bad and cried
i had her no it was two different girls
okay one one recruited by chinese to
compete for china and she got so much
shame she was crying because she made a
mistake she did not win any medals
another one when the medal look like a
star and get paid probably 30 million
dollars endorsement money and mom is
from china who wanted her compete for
chinese team
and you know i i just wonder maybe many
years later interview them again so what
do you think about china today how are
you trading now i i will not blame her
if she goes by china and they're living
there for a few years especially during
lockdown maybe she'll change her mind
already i think it's important to
mention too that athletes and famous
people in china do don't have any
freedom of speech and if they do speak
out in the government in any capacity
people will come for them so one famous
case that's kind of been memory hold is
the case of peng schwa she's one of the
most famous tennis stars as a household
name there in china she came out with
accusations against one of the party
leaders me too
in the chinese version of the metoo
movement right and she has been put on
lockdown essentially and like you'll see
because there's been a couple of times
where they put her on camera in the most
ridiculous scenarios i don't know china
has not learned how to you know prop
their videos very well they do their
fake videos very well but you could tell
she's timid everything's planted and
staged and um jack ma is also this very
famous guy he was getting there
billionaire he was outspoken for a
little bit as china looked like it was
liberalizing a little bit but then we
haven't heard from jake ma in jack
martin years and this was one of the
most famous guys there and nobody talks
about him anymore jack much
not just celebrities but religious
leaders uh cardinal cardinal joseph zen
was just arrested in china i mean this
is is an extremely high ranking person
within the catholic church
yeah pope made a deal with beijing like
uh hokay in order for the catholic
church to exist in china pope will allow
beijing to nominate three in like a
bishop for china
maximum three if after three nominations
china is not happy guess what we are
going to pick one
it's all those deals including
horrible deal yeah i think the whole
world should stand up firm against ccp
it has been evil
and and and conditioned in chinese
enslave them with their consent by
controlling all the press all the media
all the military all the natural
resources all these schools they control
everything it doesn't matter if you're
building it or not if you say something
criticize china regulators some stupid
economical laws or something
retire
donate to charity
and do not travel any threat to the
legitimacy of the government the chinese
government they were completely yes i
saw a great viral post i forgot the guy
so forgive me for not crediting you but
he said
you know how sometimes countries are bad
they get worse and so you flee them to
somewhere safe
imagine now that bad government was the
entire planet and that's globalism yep
so imagine there's nowhere to go and
that's what's scary about the idea of
chinese expansion the ccp i'm sorry the
the continent that's how i feel i have
no place to go i'm i'm fighting here i'm
not gonna be like my mother who baked in
china before get down on her knees
and that's why i have this that's why i
have this my ar-15
anyway anybody donate 200. you get a
signed copy i will mail to you
and i'm i'm you know i i need help i
have no play school team i don't know
where i can go and uh and i even don't
know when i can go back to china to see
my family and friends and i don't talk
to them about the politics some of them
are still brainwashed to cheer for the
regime how sad is that i have one family
relative tell me to take one minute to
remember cheer my mom when he had his
birthday every december your great
leader's gone let's take one minute of
silence to remember him
she had no idea how many people he
started to test he murdered
they still don't know because that's how
they enslave people by control all their
press all the media and all their
propaganda so people still saying
kumbaya i have friends who are locked
down for two months in china in shanghai
and they still tell me don't don't tell
americans well fine don't say anything
bad we've seen the videos over the past
several years of people screaming at
night when they go out in their balcony
you see everyone's screaming they're
locked in their homes there's a photo a
guy took his refrigerator opened it and
pushed it on his balcony because he's
got no food
and then and and they're gonna act like
everything's okay
like the government is and not only that
our media is also going to act like
everything is okay it's not just them
it's us
well maybe it's it's communist
infiltration yep well that look at what
happened in australia
what happened in germany today and what
happened to um
canada
you know the truckers freedom
they have to do this vaccine passport to
travel to to ship goods
what's gonna happen now
that those people who lose their jobs
lose their careers and if you dare not
to you know um comply
we free your bank account
it's i think this zero covert policy in
china also speaks to the fragility and
insecurity of the communist uh chinese
government right now they know that even
if there is a small outbreak they do not
have the hospital capacity right now to
deal with any sort of outbreak there and
that will threaten the legitimacy of the
ccp that has been dwindling moreover
there they have a sinovacs right now
their vaccine is trash compared to our
vaccines so one plus one for for our
pharmaceuticals socialist medicine china
has a socialist medicine i had a friend
entrepreneur wanted to get into hospital
reform have a like a half a private half
even government hospital
they destroyed everything he owned he
totally failed on that project almost
just become totally poor again it's
horrible they do they control certain
industries healthcare is one of them
they do not want you to use a free
market a little bit to to build more
hospitals more clinics later house
doctors
privately practice no it's totally
regulated so when you have
such a big an aging population right
people are getting old and one child
policy sometimes you cannot even take
care of you like two both very old
parents you rely on health care but then
you don't have a hospital capacity and
now nurses doctors are going out doing
madness massive testing testing you know
and by the time you want to go to
hospital they're gonna make you wait
four hours until your test is
negative to admit you by the time you're
dead i saw this woman deliver baby
without even anything under her butt a
baby came out on the road because she
was waiting for the test to come back
that's four hours wait
i think he has gone totally mad i'm
really worried about my family and
friends and also worry about the world
economy the food supply our supply
chains china port like shanghai is 13
percent about the export you know like
goods coming out from shanghai it
stopped for two months that's why people
cannot get their supplies we need a
great look at the china in the market we
look at our supply chains we need to be
smart to compete very you know
competitively in the global economy
otherwise while renowned those
totalitarian regimes
like you rely on putin for oil with
israel for oil instead of drill in your
own country and by high prices now like
the vitamin students doing is it don't
you think it's kind of crazy just don't
make sense at all but they're doing it
at the same time they're sending 40
billion dollars printed money to ukraine
hope americans who have to pay high
prices gas and diesel in new hampshire
diesel is like six dollars 30 cents per
gallon and it's interesting our money or
our government has been spending
billions of dollars on ukraine the
chinese government has been spending
insane amounts of money buying corn
futures in the united states betting on
the price of food here to go up
so that you know
who is going to really care about
regular americans live in this country
and face all those challenges and
i i know i know it's a both republican
democrats voted for this
it's kind of sad for me to see i i
i i think if i do get elected i probably
will join some liberty republicans and
and to make some sense and so we need
the people coming in to vote for the
primary vote for liberty populists
grassroots candidates who really will
speak for the common people of this
country and they instead of i don't know
who they're speaking to what they're
badly fading are they benefiting their
colonies themselves or industrial
complex or what lily can i follow
i want to jump to this story um we often
criticize the great firewall of china
and the manipulation they have on social
media and they on the internet and the
news people can get access to like the
tiananmen square massacre like you can't
find out things about it
we have the story from timcast.com
twitter unveils crisis misinformation
policy content labeled false by the
platform will be hidden during
catastrophes or emergencies wow yeah you
know exactly where that's going
we've got all these videos coming out uh
out of ukraine one of them was i love
this news story it was like cessation of
hostilities in mariopol and it's like
what does that mean and then you
actually dig into it it's like oh a
surrender from the ukrainians and
victory for for the russians but they
don't want that to be the message that
ukraine is losing
this is what i feared with the the us
disinformation board the dhs
disinformation board that the goal was
to put out talking points like here's a
list of fake news then twitter could go
oh
we we're just we're just taking down
things that the government has said is
fake news so the government is working
through twitter to censor information
now that got shut down
twitter seems to be i i don't know if
that was that was ever going to happen
but twitter is moving forward with
censorship anyway now
you're not gonna know what's really
happening in the world yeah they're
they're they're we we are following the
footsteps of everything we claim to be
against with the great firewall of china
yeah that's why i fear the country i
love becoming the country left that's my
campaign slogan because everything i see
it's like somebody wants to rule over us
and taking their tactics and terms and
strategies all straight from a communist
party's playbook who are those people
what do they want
what kind of country we want to live in
i'm i'm i'm terrified
that you know i i don't know i think
when you look at the project veritas
expose you start to realize who these
people at twitter really are
the true believers the people
we had that one guy who said they want
to change the world you know they're
here for the mission or whatever
these are cult zealots this is this is
brainwashed psychotic cult behavior but
you know what those people don't realize
they will be thrown under the bus
they're the first out yeah
people need to understand
the one thing that we all understand is
that the people who foment revolution
are the first to be purged after the
revolution why because the people
running the new government know who
overthrew the last one they don't want
it to happen to them yeah i mean we're
already seeing it happen
on a smaller scale at the social level i
mean people who were considered on the
left yesterday are being destroyed by
the left today the revolution eats its
own children that's always how it goes
that's why our kids are so important for
somebody
parents should be parents responsibility
if schools are not teaching that a real
history so we do not repeat you know
this kind of human tragedies you know
millions of millions were going to die
already dead it's like a how come are we
just repeating this
horrible horrible stories like i was
having like a ptsd last two years to see
what happened in our country because you
bring back all my horrible childhood
memories well let me ask you lily what
can we do in the united states to avoid
the fate that your country is
experiencing or the country which you
came from is experiencing i think we
have to
start to wake up ourselves
and once the way we wake up we need to
keep our family our friends our
neighbors close regardless political
party regardless who they are they might
be very lefty social justice lawyers i
want to go to talk to them because when
i have a face-to-face talk with people
have a hopefully they allow me to tell
my stories have a several conversation
like we sit down here
maybe they will start wondering um
she has a credibility to tell her
personal story maybe i need to look at
different source information lots of
people don't know the truth because they
have been conditioned for years to
believe in their own source of
information you know it's like a they
have this virtue sickness they think
they're right they think like i got
demonized all the time to you know say
i'm an evil republican i'm a racist i i
cuddle to the white nationalists or
something all kind of name corny those
people even don't know me they even
don't know me
they hate my gun picture they think that
it's like why why are you doing this
that's so scary
i'm a five one okay asian woman what is
my leverage can i tell you guys can i
tell you something funny
so uh just to the to the left of where
just where i'm pointing we have an
actual model 1861 union civil war rifled
musket
never been fired meant condition i'm a
fan of history and uh it's it's it's the
least dangerous it's not legally a gun
because you have to you know muzzle load
it like the old school days
and we've had several guests on this
show who are liberal
they won't touch it
they're they're they're afraid yeah
they're terrified of it without saying
who exactly but i come in here and um
we have real guns and uh i can bring in
someone like thomas massey and
he's like oh yeah yeah wonderful great
and then we handle we have everything
safe everything's secured we have safes
and all that stuff for any any real
firearm but uh the libertarians the
conservatives are like they know how to
handle it they know how to be safe and
anybody we're not sure of we have like a
dummy i always give people uh uh
something that can't actually fire give
them the rules and if they handle it
improperly they're cut off you can't
touch any guns anymore but these we have
up here
are our
antiques
and when when i come in with with
somebody who's a libertarian or
conservative you know they'll pick it up
they know the rules they don't point at
anybody even though this thing is so far
from firing it's it's you know not out
of the question and then we have these
liberal guests i'm like do you want to
you just take a look at the union civil
and like no
i can't touch that
scared so that's a saying when i first
came to this country i never touched gun
in china
you do feel scared of guns for some
reason
because you just had no knowledge how to
use it how to train to use it properly
right but
my husband you know from texas they took
me to shooting range and they showed me
how to you know and you know train a
little bit at the beginning i scare
everybody i just pick up guns like
opponent everybody's oh no no no no it's
like that's the first the wrong thing
you did it's like you pulled at people
i don't know i didn't know because i
just like oh what is this what is that
so they showed me they trained me and
when i first filed a shot i've it's like
it was like a shocking to me it's like i
actually feel very empowered
empowered i never had that feeling
because like i was just afraid of guns i
was afraid of guns people were
conditioning to believe that i think for
me the power was scary
like not like i was terrified of it but
it was just like the realization of how
much power what you actually had at that
moment that no one no one could say
anything to you and it's like you have
to be responsible yeah you have to
understand when you're when you're
holding that weapon
i think it's funny when people like joe
biden are like get a shotgun and i'm
like wow really
is there's no idea let off three blasts
it was like what do you say yeah fire in
the air whatever it's like first of all
idiot
so
when uh when when we went to a range and
we had an instructor talking to us the
12 gauge was the one that actually
scared everybody
you know the the five five six people
were the the you know the ar-15 people
were just like oh wow you know i didn't
expect that but the 12-gauge hurt
people's shoulders and it was like yeah
the shotgun is probably not the right
thing for a beginner but you get people
like joe biden these liberals who don't
know anything about guns and they're
just like you get a shotgun you're fired
no no no don't do that don't do that
talk to an expert go to you know if you
go to the if you go to your gun store or
your firearms uh dealer ask them for
expertise and you definitely want to get
training because i'm far from an expert
but you know there's a lot of things
that i was surprised about does he have
a misinformation all the time
oh yeah yeah yeah yes like on tv
i want to correct something i said three
blasts let me read the full quote from
him just so you can we can answer that
question does just joe spread
misinformation often this is this was
him talking to his wife all right i said
jill
if there's ever a problem just walk out
on the balcony here walk out on the
balcony here okay
walk out put the double barrel shotgun
and fire two blasts outside the house
what firstly firstly
i mean
without even considering how
unbelievably dangerous that is he said a
double barrel shotgun so waste all of
your ammo now you have to reload also no
do not aimlessly fire a gun outside of
your balcony he didn't say point it up
he said walk out put that double barrel
shotgun
and fire two blasts outside the house
what does that what does that mean it
means the man was slightly less declined
cognitively at this point because the
sentence structure works but what he's
saying is insane i like how he's your
double barrel it's like okay i guess i
think jill carries a double shotgun
around but also why would you
he's an old guy it's like what is his
elmer fudd
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get a double
barrel for home defense
so what do you think about that what do
you think about elon musk said whoever
controls his teleprompter is controlling
running this country it's like what's
that it's like it's funny because it's
halfway to the point of saying he's
puppeted but it's also he called him ron
burgundy that if whatever gets written
he says
and it's true people need to understand
this too one of the reasons joe biden
will stutter or or pause or ramble is
because the prompter prompters get stuck
you'll notice it with tucker carlson and
i maybe i'm wrong but you know having
worked with teleprompters tucker will
say things where he'll be like
now we're hearing that the government
wants to allow it illegal immigrants
it's wrong they shouldn't do that
actually and that last sentence is
nothing he's not saying anything
because the prompter's rolling and he
needs to say something as the next words
come up and so joe biden will just be
like
well
like in the quote he says he lives in
like a wooded and somewhat secluded area
before saying this but still very bad
advice like don't it's still yeah fire
off fire off what you got and then yeah
have nothing well i think i think the
middle term is coming i heard have you
heard that they lost like last ten
states who had a primary i heard they
were like a record turned out for the
republican primaries really yes and
matt kippy phrased the people told me
this morning said you know i think
um it's a message sending out to the
whole country and regardless what the
you know democrats are doing you know
they're trying to use the you know like
their base and you know they're still i
was told don't go walk to this supreme
court because there might be lots of
protests let's check check this out we
got this from the new york post gop
primary turnout suggests red wave in
november midterms republican primary
voters showed up in droves take part in
tuesday's contests
as of midday wednesday republican voters
made up 54.9 percent of the turnout in
idaho kentucky north carolina oregon and
pennsylvania according to data compiled
by jmc analytics and polling the figure
jumps to 60.9 of turnout when all 10
states that have held primary so far
this year are included whoa
see that's crazy yeah yeah
wow quote in every state where i've been
measuring turnout changes relative to
previous midterms i'm seeing a clear
advantage on the republican side
oh man
well maybe maybe maybe maybe no matter
what they're going to do that maybe some
people are waking up especially
independent even moderate democrats i
hope moderate democrats are saying what
they voted for is not what the they
expect to happen
look at elon musk he tweeted just the
other day that for the first time he's
voting republican people are waking up
and i think that's a very i'm sorry but
not that voting republican is going to
say yeah
that's what i was about to say
absolutely i mean vote republican over
democrat 100
but you know chain is only as strong as
its weakest link unfortunately in the
republican party the weakest link uh is
its leaders
leadership yeah and so what i would like
to ask you lily is what do you think the
republicans should do if they are able
to take power
i think we should come out strongly to
tell people
you know why we are different from the
democrats party so we need to
differentiate ourselves
have you noticed in the past like 30 40
years like uh everything just shift to
the more and more left oh yeah yeah what
then what is the difference
so it's like a i just get attracted and
dragged and everything's going to let no
you we have to say where's the party for
small limited government and more
freedom for small working men and for
americans first you have to
differentiate yourself they say when it
comes to right i mean there are lots of
you know women's issues around we need
to come up publicly support parental
rights and also
girls women sports right there are lots
of women who play women's sports
and now it's like they walk is basically
it's like where are the democrats who
are traditionally feminists now they're
not supporting the girls sports and the
seo is quiet about this i come out of
the public support girls woman sports
biological men should not compete in
women girls sports and how about also in
our presence you have this work prison
system if you are prisoner you are
biological male you say identify as
female you go to women's room and you
got this woman president pregnant how do
we protect those women
so their lots of sins are so confusing
and the left side is not consistent
at all when it comes to say oh we are
actually for a woman yeah one anyone
comes to abortion issue they support
women's rights to choose how about the
other issues they don't talk about it
yeah
when it comes to women's sports they
certainly have a right to choose yeah
just only when it comes to killing
babies we actually did a cartoon about
this this exact thing i want to
encourage you all to check it out but
it's leftist rediscovering biology for
this exact reason all of a sudden well
only women should be able to talk about
this now they have a definition of
womanhood and what a woman is lily i
wanted to follow up with you um i
believe earlier you said you were
against the 40 billion dollar ukraine
aid that we'd be sending them um as the
resident neocon i wanted to ask you as
we continue as russia continues to be
isolated on the world stage they're more
desperate for countries to trade with
one of the countries that is capable and
seemingly willing to do so has been
china
what would you say to somebody who says
that we should support ukraine so the
chinese understand that whatever they
try to do with taiwan they're going to
face a similar result that is what's
going on in um ukraine right now and
that by sending 40 billion dollars to
ukraine right now xi jinping is getting
the message that if he messes around in
taiwan you know taiwan might get 80
billion in arms funds so how would you
respond to somebody who says that to
stand strong against china we need to
send strong messages to russia because
again russia is needs china right now to
continue surviving how do you respond to
something like that they do have
alliance and they call each other
unlimited partners and here's what i say
first of all if i do get elected office
so what do i do i swear to protect the
defend it's not foreign countries it's
united states constitution right that's
what the rand paul said he voted he said
also think about
all of those enemies want to see
destruction of america if we dominate
our economy we become very weak because
we are creating money from same air and
inflation goes super high and then we
are putting all those printed money into
foreign countries so like a defend the
ukraine even though i'm first sending
toward ukraine people then united states
is gone so how can we be the leader in
the free world to defend the freedom
democracy
if our economy is destroyed absolutely
and if i could follow up there so um the
ccp constantly you know invades taiwan's
sovereign airspace and their sovereign
waters threatening yes threatening yeah
so they intrude on these waters and the
united states has helped go through
those straits of taiwan and try to
establish some so i guess my question
here would be if china did invade taiwan
do you think that we should send
military aid to taiwan in that situation
well that uh certainly you will not
print all that money to do that big
right there's so much stuff you can do i
don't understand
our leaders how come are not really
pushed for peace talks why sure but
specifically if china did decide to
invade taiwan do you think the united
states should fund them as we already
work with taiwan in some capacity as do
we do many of south korea japan but
should we send arms the same way that we
are doing so now to ukraine to taiwan if
invaded by china because as i see it
without our assistance again ukraine
would have fell in in two weeks and
without our assistance to taiwan taiwan
would fall in two weeks well depends on
like right now i think the policy they
have they're kind of wishy-washy it used
to be only one china right only one
china
systems yeah well that did not work out
for hong kong people
and so so morally and strongly
economically we have ties with taiwan
taiwan has 80 percent of the world
microchip supplies so of course china's
eyes on those too but we should send a
very strong message to china now instead
of waiting for them to invent taiwan the
consequences will be unbearable for you
here is one two three four you gotta lay
out right now preventively i've been
calling on biden to do that i will help
him if he calls me and and also that
when it comes to alliances you got japan
taiwan all against china you got the
indian is also and see china as right
you have all those aging countries we
need to form alliance with them right
now so prevent china from taking time we
have been supplying weapons to taiwan
already because we do not also trade
with taiwan but the morally emotionally
you know we we will support taiwan but
the sensor you don't want to push china
to even taiwan you should send them a
message now say we're going to do this
this that so don't you know china of
course is rude by mama right now but
also be honest with you china's internal
economy is is weak and they they they
did a back down even in supporting of
putin because there's some messages to
send to china but but when it comes to
the um
taiwan it's kind of funny and the
chinese people are indoctrinated to say
oh taiwan is part of china we need to
liberate taiwan at what cost and that
they don't know they're just
propagandalized and the taiwanese these
people actually they see what happened
to hong kong they don't want the one
country two systems and i think the good
is also for them to stay status call so
you don't push either side you you my
strategy would be you don't push taiwan
to declare independent that would just
provoke china but you also don't cut out
to china let them to do whatever they
want so you need to have some kind of
balance foreign policy is all about
diplomatic balances alliances and also
negotiate from strength not weakness
right now we're not strong if right now
we got word that china had launched a
ground invasion in taiwan do you think
the u.s should intervene
wait boots on the ground or send
military aid to some okay so
should the u.s help in any way
like so we've got strike groups we've we
you know we've we've sailed to the
strait of taiwan and stuff with our
carriers
i'm curious if you think if china were
to say you know like right now the
taiwan sent out an emergency call china
is is doing a hard invasion right now
should the u.s intervene
well it depends on when you mean
intervene i do not support we have war
with china i don't
we're not in the position to have any
wars and the congress should declare war
if they are going to declare war
officially per the constitution duties i
have been this country for almost 34
years and i have seen endless wars not
declared by congress but just by
executive branch there are some people
it's like they always want to you know
constantly you know meddling in the
world affairs where our country is
getting weaker and weaker
so no boots on the ground but let's say
it was a similar situation where we want
to send 40 billion dollars worth of arms
to taiwan what do you think about that
well you you can look at the specific
numbers and they already send lots of
money to ukraine they ran out of very
quick and do we have the list of stuff
spent on and for this bill people don't
have time to read and to debate then
boom right now sent to ukraine and then
how do we keep track do you know how
much billions dollars the kobe still
means money wasted even bill moore is
very upset about that
you know you think he's liberal but he's
like
what happens why are they still paying
money we cannot even keep track of how
many billions dollars got the fraud you
know scammed
that's how they handle your money
there are similarities a lot of
similarities between ukraine and taiwan
but i also think that there's really big
differences like the the already
diplomatic ties we have the taiwan all
the already military agreements the fact
that china's not just threatening taiwan
that they've actually been sinking
vietnamese ships that they've been
threatening war with australia that
they've been doing
essentially drive-bys of alaska and
hawaiian waters so while we do have
issues with russia
the issue with china is very very
similar
but also relatively different i would
probably fall into the
man i would not want to see a war with
china and and the conflict would be akin
to if russia and cuba like if if if the
u.s if russia invaded guantanamo bay or
like
not not that they really would it's not
the same thing but the proximity i mean
so i'd probably say it's a really bad
idea if china invaded right now for us
to send in physical intervention at that
point it's like if it gets that point
we've lost taiwan yeah i think there's a
big there's there's a lot of issues that
are going on here but also that it would
happen quickly um right
they would surround it and then they're
in when despots get um desperate to gin
up support from their population they go
to war and many chinese people chinese
citizens are primed to believe taiwan is
a part of their country so in order to
drum support in a desperate time xi
jinping may launch on you know a bad
strategically poor attack on taiwan and
trying to drum up support at home i
think putin's also trying to do
something similar with that but lily
what are you so is biden
that's why that's why you know i i don't
know what they did before even and putin
went to ukraine you know it's like a you
know you saw the signs on the wall how
come there's no negotiations and no you
know sections put into place i think
right now that we got to send a very
clear message to china what's going to
happen if you do take this step
and also the same time we need to really
think about you know make our
country competitive again for all they
manufactured jobs that all sent to china
before and it's like
people always blame corporations
corporation got to make money right they
go to go where the cheap labor is and
cheap goods are but as they're saying is
though they hire taxes in america and
also too much regulation it's like
you're pushing private business people
out to you know source overseas so if
you want to really have a pro america
you know like americans first then you
need to cut the regulations you need to
cut the taxes to bring those jobs home
and and and why do we want to rely on
those countries anyway because we i
think as americans we had a delusion
about china oh if they just do free
market capital them get rich and they
will become democratic country it did
not happen
it got worse china is going backwards
now they are talking about this cultural
revolution 2.0 in china as i said white
guards red girls and xi jinping once
people now study his she's little red
books remember mao's need to read books
she has a xi jinping thought yeah a red
app for you to download on your phone
when you study past tests yes your
social credit score go up that's how
they keep track you it's a red app yeah
it's very sad and i think very telling
unfortunately about american psychology
and even american conservatism that
there was a very uh popular idea that as
long as we introduced the mechanisms
that would allow china to be to become
more economically prosperous they would
become a country that has values in line
with ours as well as a country that
behaves well and doesn't oppress its own
people
there was no reason for believing that
but unfortunately what's happened is
people have responded to marxism by
adopting its premises but trying to
argue from a different position so
rather than giving what the conservative
or traditional response should have been
which is well marxists are wrong because
there's more to the world than what is
purely material and simply having
material prosperity does not make a
country good or virtuous and doesn't
necessarily solve its problems what
conservatives ended up saying was and
what the neoliberal order ended up
saying was well actually it is the case
that being materially prosperous solves
all of your problems but capitalism does
that rather than communism i think we
tried to free trade our way into
relationships with china and russia and
like this upcoming era is us seeing that
failure at doing so so the idea was
liberalize china trade with china ping
pong diplomacy you know try to become
closer and then if we're tied together
then there's less risk of a conflict
germany had the same idea with russia
nordstrom won let's do another nordstrom
pipeline for the past decades people
were warning germany it's this is going
to be used as a political tool against
them but no germany argued that we need
to liberalize free uh free trade with
russia
in um integrating our societies and our
businesses together will help avoid
conflict but we're seeing these despots
and authoritarian regimes just use this
um as a leverage against uh other
countries around the world absolutely
and it's because we don't understand
their thinking so this is something
lauren southern said on the show but
basically the chinese government
understands the way that america thinks
very well that's why they come out in
sport of blm and they say the american
police are racist even though china is a
horrific leader the chinese communist
party is a horrifically racist regime
you know during a coffee shot down they
kick out lots of black people leaving
china mcdonald's banned them didn't it
does it yeah and there's a there's a
sign to say
you cannot go inside a mcdonald's to eat
worse they have camps for uyghurs um
cultural genocide yes and and they look
like the racist ccp say they're saying
so our war corporations like this name
and they they have business with china
and and china is actually in a very
racist country and they were subject to
their rules but they're doing the
totally opposite here it's like a
there's no consistency so it's all
follow the money right you know likey
the same thing and and
so i don't know say china has leverage
also against the free world because lots
of free world countries rely on china
for supply chains and they also look at
chinese 1.4 billion of them think about
how much money we can make from their
market and the chinese government knows
that they use their leverage to
negotiate to say hey
if you and support me in the united
states then my nature to go to you know
like china market you know black rock
these manage china's painting funds
it's interesting that you mentioned that
they import most of their resources but
if somebody could fact check me on this
i believe they import 80 of their oil so
a quick blockade with um some of our you
know we have a ton of different our navy
is the true blue water navy on the
planet so it was uh
well no i hear what you're saying i'm
actually looking this up right now to
yeah
another thing is that because the free
trade uh like american free trade has
facilitated the ccp and being the
country that it's trying to be so thanks
to our ability and allowing free trade
to exist on the world's waters they're
able to import and export they don't
need to pay to trust that you know the
trading will work out but in the future
as we're seeing you know this world
order kind of break down we'll be seeing
less of that so it's not reliable when
you have a political dictatorship right
even though i love free trade i love yes
we all hope that free trade will bring
people together and don't fight the
walls but they're saying though when you
trade with a dictatorship country like
russia or china guess what you get one
crazy leader
then it's not reliable of sudden you can
have supply chain issues they can cut
you out and they can bully you and and
they will use the money they made from
you to go expand their power have you
heard about china dream xi jinping has a
china dream by
2049 china will be number one dominant
economical and political military power
in the world how is it going to achieve
that
bring down united states
so we that's why we need to be careful
there's the old saying it's attributed
to lenin though who knows if he said it
that the capitalists will sell us the
rope with which we will hang them
exactly yeah yeah we've given away our
manufacturing
yeah our borders have fallen
and now you have the talk of these these
these big international treaties
which on the surface don't sound all
that alarming
then when you realize that
we don't make our own medicine
if china right now just cut us off from
manufacturing we'd be in serious trouble
like if we actually went to war we we
are we are we are in trouble i suppose
the the neoliberal idea was if we have
these trade agreements between nations
the war wouldn't happen but all that
happened was china started using it to
manipulate us
at risk this next era of the supply
chain is completely breaking down and
countries having to self-produce or just
with their allies it's going to have
huge consequences lily you mentioned
earlier it was like 80 percent of the
semiconductors in the world are produced
on taiwan mexican chips yes there's
going to be huge consequences to that
other other things like oil a lot of
this places is all focused in one part
of the earth so free trade kind of
helped facilitate that in trade but as
we see that break down
the consequences will be dire i still
think
leather
immigrants like me still say america
is still the
shining city on the hill for freedom
lovers all over the world so how are we
going to focus on our efforts and time
and to actually you know defend protect
our country
sometimes from enemies with yin
it's a big question so and of course if
we could you know morally diplomatically
economically help other countries that's
great but right now
i'm just worried about america is going
to fall
and then what going to do who are we
going to help are we going to subject to
the the united nations
well they they give up our sovereignty
and
but you know china is one of the major
players in united nations they're on the
council of human rights they're on one
of the situations security council
on anything yeah and the who actually
did work with them and cover up the kovi
and the telling the truth to the world
and we don't even go after china to say
where is orange in of the covey aware is
your patient zero
instead of were just buying lots of ppe
from them yeah it it just does not make
sense let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that member
segment coming up for you at 11 p.m and
i think it might end up being uh
particularly not family friendly is it
usually is not family friendly but this
one might be really just not for
not for the uh not for the family let's
read some super chats
all right what we got here
christina h says lily with a whole bunch
of emojis with hearts in the eyes oh
there you go
thank you and asses tim's looking like a
mint chocolate chip snack
you color i love it
indeed yes
mr sly trip says bulk shirts for the win
what is that what does that mean bulk
shirts i did buy like just a big stack
of these shirts yeah that's what it
means you just have a bunch of shirts in
bulk
yeah yeah actually i have like
i i have like 50 of those gray shirts i
always buy tons of the same shirt
because i wear the same shirt forever
well but now you've leveled up this is
like tim 2.0 you got enough xp in the
outfit well it's funny because people
will make like memes of me but it'll be
me wearing the gray and black baseball
tee from like six five or six years ago
and then it's just like man i haven't
worn that shirt in years and they're
making memes about it it's like do you
even watch anything i make because
that's like a long no they don't they
don't is it justin teal or does do you
have other colors too oh yeah other
clothes nice yeah i mean for the most
part it's just like black and gray and
then like i have this one and then i got
the uh
the uh black and gold for uh andy rcto
the the uh and and cap colors
best colors the best colors
okay uh
bobby bob yells dragon lady is that is
that uh is that considered disrespectful
or is that considered a funny thing well
it's funny you call dragon lady because
i was born in a dragon year which is the
most auspicious chinese zodiac you know
out of 12. so i will take that as a
compliment but i'm tiger mom in this
tiger years
for dragon lady that's right
well i'm a um positive dragon lady
do you guys remember when the i believe
it was lieutenant governor of virginia
was elected the picture they used for
her it was a black woman holding a gun
it would be so awesome if lily were to
have a successful campaign and if this
was the picture that they used when they
had to say that lily was the winner in
her new hampshire um second
congressional district so be sure to
check her out that's right thank you
thank you all right trent leywell says
hey tim after listening to last night's
members only segment i just have to ask
don't you think the ukrainian people
deserve autonomy yes they do they should
be responsible for themselves in their
attempts to get it and it's uh um
i mean it's it's it's difficult i have
ukrainian friends and i certainly don't
like what russia is doing but i think i
think the us is overstepping
in a million ways it's it's one thing to
be like hey we're going to provide
military to this country it's another
thing to be like we're going to provide
military aid we're going to send border
border troops to uh poland to deal with
the influx of him of refugees we're
going to send u.s forces for for
training we're going to send 54 billion
dollars at a time when our economy is
crumbling and then we're going to
provide the intelligence to be used by
the ukrainians for blowing up russian
flagships and i'm just like
it's one thing to be like let's help
this country it's another thing to be
like we're directly at war with russia
and lying about it
all right
adrian contreras says oh my god i want
to give this lady a huge hug also was
monkey pox ground zero the wuhan monkey
virology research center center
interesting
perhaps i don't know i don't know no i i
don't know where monkey pox is i think
someone went to canada and they came
back massachusetts and now they have it
all right
omg puppy says there are two kinds of
monkey pox this one is less dangerous
one percent fatal and not easy to
transmit only contagious after symptoms
appear the congo version is 10 fatal but
this is the nigerian version ah yes yes
yes
well all right
jerkoff juggernaut says hey timmy might
want to look into why samsung decided to
add the azov flag into their emoji list
what did they really why right now that
can't be that can't be true
the azov battalion is becoming like
amazingly is the wrong word to describe
it but amazingly mainstream um so i've
been covering these ukraine protests
that happened weekly in new york city so
first it started off with just yeah we
love ukraine then the next one they were
chants specifically for the azov
battalion which i posted to twitter got
a couple million views no big deal then
the next protest was specifically we
support the azov battalion and like a
dozen people with signs of the actual
wolf's angel wolf's angle which was a
controversial symbol used by the ss
panzer division and other neo-nazi
groups but it was just so interesting
how normalized they became so quickly
and how public they were willing to be
with these extremely controversial um
symbols so well yeah i mean because the
left doesn't have any actual principles
if a group is not useful to them if it's
hateful if it's useful to hate a group
they hate them if it's expedient they
don't uh this is why
you know hitler and uh
and stalin had a deal right we've seen
communists and nazis work together in
the past yeah david c cronk senior says
conspiracy theory tim poole starts
monkey pox scare so that he can continue
playing fauci for freedom tunes
we haven't had a fouchy episode in a
long time no that's why that's why you
ran out of the nice shirts and you have
to go to the teal ones you can't afford
it anymore man the the button ups were
too expensive i leased them you know
what i mean
it's 300 bucks a month
i don't buy it that's for fools you lose
80 of the value as soon as you take that
shirt off the lot that's right as soon
as you clip that tag
yep all right
sam
whitehurst says i have a friend who is
so blackpiled that he believes the
potential collapse is inevitable and
will be so great that no one will
survive i'm very worried about him but
don't know how to give him hope any
advice
i certainly think that we're we're
headed for a major collapse in a variety
of ways but that i i don't think
anything's going to be bad for any of us
i was going to say is your friend tim
maybe
the idea that the collapse happens and
everyone just dies it's like here's
here's here's what i imagine i imagine
there will be some kind of collapse your
buying power will go down gas will be 15
and 20 dollars a gallon the economy will
just will crumble to a great degree
everyone will have to become
substantially more personally
responsible and they will
and there will be a period of great
strife but
within a few months you'll probably have
adapted to it and we'll all probably
just start to rebuild and it's it's not
the apocalypse you know i think i think
humans are adaptive and clever so
things can break apart but i think we'll
build them back up
i mean for me out here in the middle of
nowhere might be a bit more relaxing
just go out and tend to the chickens all
day
there you go and eat eat the wine
berries i i'm so excited for wine berry
season you guys well
i would say this it's much easier said
than done but i think
one of the key components to this is
helping your friend realize that the
things that make his life more
comfortable prior to this
collapse he believes is going to happen
are not
the things that give his life meaning
a lot of people use being black pills as
an excuse to be nihilist and did not do
a lot with their lives but if you're
going to be black pilled at least be
black pilled in the direction where
you're like eff it i'm actually going to
do as much whatever i wanted to do with
my life because of the black belt so
there's two directions you could take it
but
i i still have a hope for america i'm uh
still optimistic
that's why i'm fighting we just need a
lot more to push back and to do little
things our own way to
help to prevent this
otherwise imagine the world would be
very dark place if american falls right
amen
american liberty is dim it's a dark
world yeah that's why it's time to push
back now you cannot you say oh i'm free
to be called racist i'm i'm afraid to
lose my job lose my career lose my
business but you're gonna lose
everything anyway it's better just get
involved and activate it now before it's
too late right that's why we tell people
hey you can always move to new hampshire
before it's too late
all right julian says tim it's time for
you to start a skate team and make rad
videos like land yachts we have that in
the works actually we're building our
new facility i'm talking with some
really great construction guys we're
going to be building an awesome new new
studio and recreational and work
facility and we've got some plans for it
we actually have a whole bunch of
skateboards we have tim cast skateboards
of all sizes and we have step on snake
and find out skateboards we have a ton
of them i think we have like a hundred
of them or wow no maybe like 60 or 70. a
lot of them skateboards
well the decks like the wood part i
don't i don't know what i'm what i just
i got them because i was like these are
cool and i thought the step no the step
on snack and find out sure was hilarious
and it sold really well so i made
skateboards
maybe we should sell them because people
would probably want to buy those yeah we
should do that i just i don't know we
don't have a mechanism for selling them
oh yeah yeah we have them though yeah
maybe we'll just give them out maybe
i'll just have someone go around a skate
park and give them up we send a bunch to
a skate shop for free because it's just
good marketing just so that all of a
sudden the skate shop has free boards
they can sell make money help keep the
the shop up and running but then also
you get a whole bunch of kids riding
around on tim cast skateboards it's just
good marketing
i mean and within two days the graphics
completely ruined and no one knows it's
a tim cascade board you should sign to
that girl from yesterday
um and also by the way i checked out her
instagram she actually instagram storied
the part uh part of the show yesterday
where we spoke about it oh she did yeah
i'll check that out cool sweet
shout out
taylor silverman right yeah yeah you can
follow taylor may silverman um yeah i've
been in touch with her where were were
you know i want to have her out and have
a conversation about about the issues
and her experience and stuff i think
she's doing interviews or something but
i don't know for sure
but uh yeah maybe some some cool stuff
in the skateboarding world coming soon
shred somebody shredkowski says nh voter
here lily what is your stance on nuclear
power and how will you fight to lessen
the role of the federal government when
elected
well i
i hope i can help to reduce the um
federal government
empowers and also the not be so reckless
vendors i think the nuclear um
power energy you see talk about the
nuclear
well let uh
i have to look into that nuclear issues
but and do you know how many we have how
many
how many nuclear in new hampshire
no yeah you talk about power plant right
like energies yeah
you know i i support we actually explore
all channels all resources to increase
energy production and i heard actually
nuclear is pretty good i'm a fan of
nuclear yeah and i think you know moscow
actually even talked about that right
it's pretty safe france use lots of that
right i think that new hampshire has a
two but the one is active another one
for some reason just not really active
and
now we have to develop all sorts of
energy supplies we we cannot rely on
dictatorship companies like countries
for example biden is baking for like a
venezuelan and then later in middle east
means like he's asking people to supply
us all your energy all the time from
other countries but we cannot depend on
them what can we depend ourselves
remember under previous president we
were actually exporting the energy to
other countries and the government the
federal government is way too big
and
and the way expensive and and people are
suffering because they constantly you
know cannot balance budget and
constipating money so inflation going to
be even higher and the energy cost will
go higher it's gonna hurt working people
and billionaires might not get so much
hurt right they still fly their private
jet right even though they say hey we
have climate change but hey we're gonna
fly our private jet to go to the
helsinki climate summit they're gonna
all go on their private and buy houses
uh buy houses on the beaches even though
in 12 years that you know we will not
have those you know places so so you you
have to put things in perspective that
you know call them out if you see
hypocrisy and the best way just become
independent thinkers don't believe those
kind of rhetorics anymore
all right raymond g stanley jr says tim
you hear about sri lanka no food no gas
there's riots they may resort to
cannibalism that doesn't sound so bad
you ever eat with a butt
that does sound really really bad
oh jesus that's what i was talking about
this earlier um that you know you get to
the point
we've not seen
a famine with cities of these sizes
do you know under mao that the people in
my home's province sichuan they were so
hungry their kids died for starvation
and they swapped their children's bodies
to eat to
survive and it's like not documented not
even talking about it but the chinese
people from china know
there was cannibalism during the mass
famine
outside of the cities they don't even
really know what goes on because there's
a lot of you know the cities were
protected by the government but the
peasants who were forced to turn over
their crops to these cities by the
government they had nothing left for
themselves to eat that's happening now
with uh water in california i don't know
i it's been seven years or so since i've
been down there but the drought when i
was there the cities take the water from
the poor farming communities
because they can vote they cannot vote
them they have more power
i don't like to see their repeat in
history
all right benjamin wheeler says tim love
the show thanks for having lily back on
with the elon musk hit pieces coming out
alleging sexual misconduct do you think
this will somehow prevent him from
acquiring twitter no i think elon has to
buy twitter now the the he's bugs
bunnied them as it were meaning at first
he was trying to buy twitter and
everyone was like no no you can't do it
then all of a sudden he's like the
deal's on hold because of spam bots and
they're like you can't quit you have to
buy it now
it's the meme it's the me but seriously
when when uh the babylon beer with the
article it says ingenious move donald
trump comes out in support of
impeachment so democrats must oppose
that's right elon musk questions buying
twitter now they're like no no you have
to buy it now and he's like i guess i do
and so many people were defending like
the worst people who are currently the
owners of um twitter i believe a large
percent of it is owned by one of the
saudi princes somebody fact-checked me
on that but he came out saying like oh
no i disagree with musk trying to buy
any part of twitter but it's like bro
you work for one of the in one of the
most corrupt countries on planet earth
so
ski says as an alaskan would you
consider getting sarah palin on she's
running for congress in alaska this year
that would be amazing i would love to
have sarah palin on yeah we can talk
about how tina fey said i can see russia
from my house and then people actually
thought that was sarah palin who said it
yeah crazy yeah
talk about fact-checking satire you know
where was snopes back then
that's why snopes does it because
they're like there are a lot of dumb
people yeah but i mean we've sort of
talked about this on the show before but
the uh study they conducted to determine
that people were believing babylon b was
completely pseudo-scientific right they
faked it yeah they they changed the
headlines of the satire article yeah to
make them sound more believable right
they removed the jokes changed them to
make them sound more believable and then
asked people if they were believable you
know tim if you are aware there are
record number of republican women
running for congress this year wow
records with record turnout so we're
going to have a whole wow think about
that
the congress will be disproportionately
republican women
relatively i should say well 2018
remember lots of democrat women got
elected
and uh so so it's like
yeah so like uh restaurants dropping
republicans big ten too you know if i
can run as a chinese immigrant who come
here with nothing i'm living american
dream that's the best proof right hey
this woman came here with nothing
couldn't even speak english she's
running for congress imagine if i do
when
it would be historical right of course
not about me it's about my messages it's
about our country it's about my children
like i go everywhere where my children
and baby pictures in my little gold
locket here yeah you know i'm i keep
telling them i'm doing this for you i'll
give you campaign update before you wrap
up oh yeah zach
see goldstein says as uh as a faithful
next morning listener i have to agree
with chat last night hearing libby talk
about how she is raising her son she is
beyond a just just a good mother but
should be an example for most women on a
separate but equal note the nourishment
was on display for us shim cast fans
love all of you stay classy stay classy
zach that was a very very classy super
chat yes
the classiest
raymond g stanley jr says lily is more
pro-american than most politicians
that's funny but i think when you come
from ccp-controlled china
to america escaping it you're like this
is a great place and i think for the the
uh progressive leftist millennials who
grew up here
i would love to buy anyone you know i've
made the offer
to many of these progressives i was like
i will buy you a plane ticket
to one of these countries you think is
doing well like you wanna go to
venezuela you know and talk to these
people and meet them and see how they
live and see what they think i'll get
you the plane ticket can you invite aoc
to debate me here oh i no she would
never do that she would never she would
she would accuse me of harassing her
something like that she's getting
engaged today or it came out today that
she's oh yeah yes and then if i was like
uh if i reached out to aoc's like um
campaign manager whatever and said we'd
love to have on the show she'd tweet tim
poole emailed my manager trying to hit
on me and ask for a date
i have engaged him
i'd like to debate somebody you know if
they are you know um open-minded to come
even bill maher said actually more
conservatives go on to his show right
take his challenge but then lots of the
another side they don't show up on his
you know what i'm afraid of they don't
have arguments i think vosh is always
interested in in having those kinds of
debates maybe maybe we can good for him
yeah maybe maybe we can get a leftist or
progressive to come on
maybe i i'd ideally it would be a
politician so you know we'll see well
yeah we'll try that'd be great well you
guys have debates against your um who
you're running against i know it's in
september when um yeah september 13th is
our primary and
before the primary republican country
like a committee they will host debates
like they say i have basically one
republican opponent in the primary there
are primarily
five but only one in the campaigning
that's why i call myself a front runner
in terms of money raised and national
like a news coverage like including
youtube ratio like this so i'm a
frontrunner the thing is so if i won the
nomination i heard there's only one
debate or something on wmur which is the
only tv station we have in new hampshire
to debate my democrat uh opponent will
there be a republican debate uh with you
and their republican was there a
republican president i just wasn't sure
yeah republican september 13th yeah
that's republican primary but i don't
know that uh if if the wmur is going to
host the primary debate just for all
republicans or not i was going to say
tim cass could probably host a better
debate than they can so
yeah but
they have to come here
right
i mean no we have the mobile studio but
we certainly wouldn't do a debate we
could rent a a venue and and probably
put something on what we'll have to we
would need to hire a big production
company who knows how to do stuff like
that we could do it
we should look into it i i would like to
encourage people to come to primary vote
for me because in new hampshire
anybody who's undeclared they can come
to republican primary take the ballot to
to vote
and that will guarantee my primary
victory then can go on to general which
is less than two months away after that
and to against this incumbent democrat
she has been there for 10 years she
votes with pelosi 98 of time
and
and
people say this is a year for really
republican to defeat her they tried for
past 10 years and so so i'm doing very
well in terms of my messages and thank
you the team has the followers you are
the best donors after february first you
know an interview i got over a thousand
donors from that show so so now i need
to raise a hundred fifty thousand
dollars by the end of this quarter but
uh uh you also went on tucker carlson
right yes
certainly you know you did very well
did we did we beat tucker
well so far from top carson's which is
only last week last thursday night i got
over 120 donors from from that show but
i got the 1000 from you two hours show
so i'm hoping after tonight if 10 000
people here give me
20 bucks each
oh i can win this i will be the first
kennedy
and and the first republican woman to go
to congress but groping men in china
communist country i'm just thinking
about
a a a chinese immigrant
having a conversation or like you know
speaking out against you know like aoc
so you have a chinese immigrant who
escaped chinese communism
speaking to a progressive leftist who's
complaining about america it's just
going to be a a it's going to be a sight
i would debate her but here is singles
not just aoc there are 97 members
of
progressive caucus members in the u.s
countries house of representatives 97
that's the biggest political caucus they
decide what kind of policies bills they
want to pass i i'm outnumbered but you
need the property you like me and plus
10 other people like me to go there or
more all right let's read some more we
got glacio says lily i'm a graduate
student based in brazil currently
studying how ccp exports censorship
trying to start raising alarm in my uni
about how we are following in their
footsteps thesis might turn into a book
is there a way i can send it to you
oh great well we'll keep
on communication there of course you
know and there is my website
ladytonguewilliams.com
when you push the donate button and
there is a mailing address like po box
number and you can send me to the there
you know good job thank you for doing
that you know chinese communist party is
exporting everything from china
to free world and we have to be awake to
resist that
yeah we're having to abide by chinese
standards if you want to make like a
movie or something now and you don't
want to have to change it for the united
states and china you just make it
according to the chinese standards
becomes the issue so yeah hollywood kind
of compromise on that yeah it's a huge
challenge yeah duloc says hello
neighbors from martinsburg west virginia
i am 25 years old have a wife and a
three-year-old son i carry my gun
everywhere i go i moved here from
maryland in 2021 i refuse to live in a
state that doesn't let me defend my
family here here
allison goddard says goddard says we
love you all so much that we have named
some of our foster puppies after you we
have tim ian luke tucker brandon tatum
candace megan kristen kaley marjorie and
bella all up for adoption through god's
dogs i couldn't help but notice not a
single sheamus well this is the thing
that's probably the first batch of dogs
where one of them didn't get named
sheamus because nine times out of ten
when i tell someone my name oh my friend
had a dog named sheamus or oh i had a
dog named james all the time that's
funny and that's a lot of those names
it's a very common one isn't it
yeah yeah get an irish sheepdog and name
him sheamus
yeah no do you do whatever you want it's
your dog tim i would that wouldn't that
be funny if it's like hey sheamus and
then you you come out and at the same
time you you say what up and the dog
barks at the same time you know or wrong
yeah well that's i mean i can
communicate with it and i'm like oh not
you sheamus hey sheamus did you want to
go get food uh also well it wouldn't be
for i know you'd be inviting the dog too
by the way i love how this person like
before they included my name they
started like naming the dogs after
audience members it's like a 20 long
list what audience members no no no no i
was kidding i was being i was kidding
because the core cast was name and there
was a bunch of people that's pretty
funny yeah name the dog sheamus
we'll have to do it
sheamus which one not you
all right let's see
john carranza says tim need help been
preparing to vote in the midterms but
i'm having trouble finding when and
where know any websites that share that
info from south carolina
find out what your district is and then
go to ballotpedia and look it up and
that should have all the information i
believe uh there's probably better
websites for it but you know that's the
best i can do
i mean you probably just
yeah validpedia well but
depending on what you google you might
get some fundraising sites or who knows
normally the local parties all have that
information you know local town and they
have information where to vote
rita ho says taipei act
s-1678 signed by trump on 3 26 20 allows
u.s to provide direct military aid to
taiwan there is no such u.s law for
ukraine
interesting
vik says as a cuban american it's always
refreshing to hear from survivors of
communism let's not let taiwan become
another bae of pigs i'm anti-war but
weak men create hard times tim god bless
you your crew and the chickens
especially the chickens
chicken city famous
that's right all right let's grab some
super cheats
all right
comic nut says tim i'm the guy who
called the rugged man weak you're still
a good guy also every everyone that
people in the states still have some
kind of virtue i.e guns and also miss
lily i'm 6'5 and built like a brick
house if you need some extra muscle just
ask and i'll keep the spies away
oh wow thank you i appreciate it yes and
and i also lots of people are praying
for me and continue to do so and
but i could use some help if i go to
your tongue i will say hey who is my
supporter showed up here
marion holtzman says youtube limits me
to 500 a week to support opposing voices
to the mainstream media this week it's
your turn thank you for your interesting
guests thank you very much i really do
appreciate it and everybody else with
super chats i really do appreciate it
speak out against the manipulation and
the lies
woods precision arm says lily we follow
you anywhere you kick ass from a woods
precision arms no good there you go
there was a really good uh super chat
maybe it's at the bottom we'll see we'll
see if i can find it
uh what do we have here
hydrogen haze says if we take veto proof
majority it's time to start stripping
the executive branch of authority by
dissolving federal agencies blm atf dhs
epa etc yes lily would you like to
repeal the nfa
national firearms act
sounds like some store right
yeah
so
well that i think that there's really no
need for that to exist you know um
get back to state
it's not the federal job
all those three later agencies lots of
them really are not
you know constitutional to exist in the
first place that's how our government at
the federal level gets super big right
starts taking over the states take over
it's not worth it stay right i want i
want to risk like i love florida the
governor he already stands up for
florida do you think a person has a
right to a a
fully automatic rifle
do you think people should have a right
to have a fully automatic rifle
i don't say why not
when you when you fight a tyranny you
use whatever you can i'm just worried
about you know there's no guarantee our
government will never become tyranny
it's going that way yeah the national
firearms act basically makes it
difficult to acquire uh selective fire
rifles that can do burst or full auto so
and it makes it impossible to get
suppressors and it's i mean repeal them
how about repeal all unconstitutional
gun control laws which is all of them
yeah
our rights to self-defense exist before
any loss even even scalia said there
were limits on the second amendment and
so i'm just kind of like i don't know if
i agree with that that's a modern
interpretation and if we go by modern
interpretations then eventually woman
won't be a real word it'll be whimx and
it won't be in the constitution at all
well if they ever lived under communism
then we have some conversations to have
with those people right because i
survived that for me it's very easy i
see things clearly all right we got one
more let's read this one btk says tim
explain how the u.s abandoning ukraine
after george h.w bush and clinton signed
and you've agreed with the abandonment
your ukrainian friends must be proud of
your view this is actually a really good
critique of me and i accept it there was
uh there was a treaty that had to do
with nuclear disarmament and the u.s
promised to protect ukraine in the event
of aggression from a foreign nation if
they chose to give up their nukes in
which case fair point fair point i think
the u.s needs to stop being wishy-washy
i would have preferred if the u.s went
in with a treaty with ukraine years ago
when they were actually working when
when you when ukraine was actually
trying to get one and i think it would
have been smarter to implement a no-fly
zone before any aggression started when
the bite administration knew and had
warned us and i didn't believe it so
fair point fair point i don't i don't
know how to reconcile that i don't like
the idea of the u.s getting involved in
in eastern europe but if the u.s does
have that agreement i think we should
absolutely review it and if we are
beholden to that treaty then i think
we're beholden to that treaty
good point i definitely wanted to read
that one because we did talk about that
before a lot of people have brought it
up and i will stress
we told ukraine if you give up your
nukes we got your back
depending on what that fully meant in
terms of the law i think would we have
to review and i don't want to jump the
gun too soon but i'm i'm just very weary
of the us at a time of crisis and
economic strife to be sending so much
money overseas and potentially risking
world war iii but uh again can i get a
quick note on that treaties are treaties
but when
things hit the fan and what will
actually happen i feel like are two
different things treatises have been
broken like we right now we're under a
nato commitment to like cover the baltic
states like lithuania like if russia did
invade are we willing to go to nuclear
war over estonia lithuania most people
can't point these countries out on a map
and you know there's a deeper
conversation here about what what these
treaties mean so some of the tickets
i do have
independence friends in my tongue
and an older woman she told me when we
had lunch together she said i'm so
stressed out says what so i'm so worried
about whoa nuclear war world war iii how
about my kids my grandchildren and she
said how come our government is not you
know trying the maximum map you know
like the way to do you know peace talks
and negotiate you know sit down with
everybody she's very worried
all right we're gonna we're gonna get
into that members only show but i just
want to read one from the regular checks
that i i did just notice it
and uh where did it just go did they
just get rid of it
oh there it is adam gould iii says nice
shirt tim do they make them for men
roasted roasted all right everybody
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have a members only show coming up at 11
11 or so p.m no shows tomorrow because i
have a very important business meeting
so we have to be i have to actually fly
out super early i'm getting up at like 4
a.m or whatever and then i'm gonna have
to go fly to a a a different city for
for important work but everything will
return on monday as per usual you can
follow the show at tim cast irl you can
follow me personally at tim cast on
instagram twitter or wherever lily do
you want to shout anything out
yes i i need everybody please and try
your best i know time is hard if 10 000
people donate 20 bucks
you know within the next two months i
can one please help i need the
volunteers too if you live in new
hampshire contact me
lillytownwilliams.com when you go there
donate as i said 200 bucks you get a
signed copy for my ar-15 pictures
yes thank you so much for having me
absolutely yeah lily it has been
fantastic to have you on as per usual i
would like to promote freedom tunes it's
a youtube channel i run we make
educational cartoons mostly political
satire though we release the cartoon
today on the left mysteriously
rediscovering gender i'm sorry
biological sex as abortion bands uh have
begun to occur so go over to
freedomtunes.com put your email in the
little box and when the site launches on
may 30th you will get notified you'll
also have the opportunity to uh
subscribe for extra exclusive content
hey everybody i'm a lot thank you guys
so much for tuning in i cover protests
and on the ground report for tim cast
you could find my social media for
twitter in the description below i'm
also barely informed with a lot on
youtube and instagram um thanks for
tuning in guys
and i just want to say thank you guys
again for tuning in for our time with
lily i always enjoy everything she has
to tell us and i'm really optimistic for
this race hopefully it's good you guys
can follow me on twitter and mines.com
at sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchlist.me if you haven't already
noticed pop culture crisis now goes live
i believe it is what is it uh sunday
through third year sunday through
thursday sunday through thursday at 3
p.m i think so a little bit different
from our schedule because they go sunday
through thursday which i often thought
about but they got it and if you want to
hang out and watch pop culture
commentary movies actors drama and all
that stuff it's youtube.com pop culture
crisis check them out it's uh it's the
the latest show one of our late one of
the shows we've launched over at
timcast.com and now on youtube and we
will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye
you